[WIND RUSHING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL STEINMETZ: So,
our ultimate contribution,
our ultimate
product, is not just
going to be an app-- though
we're good at that, Diego.
And it's not going to be about
delivering the absolute best
weed in the world,
which we have.
We're here to stand for the
clean cannabis movement.
[APPLAUSE]
LAURA LING: Meet
Michael Steinmetz,
a pot entrepreneur who's trying
to change the face of weed.
Michael, what did you do before
you got into the marijuana
industry?
MICHAEL STEINMETZ:
So originally, I'm
an engineer by background.
I started off going to school
at Carnegie Mellon University,
and then I worked at
NASA for some time.
After that, I moved
into investment banking.
Really quickly realized
I didn't love that.
LAURA LING: What attracted
you to this industry?
MICHAEL STEINMETZ:
I've always wanted
to see it go mainstream
in a different light
than putting a stigma
and stereotype around it.
LAURA LING: Michael is the
co-founder of a marijuana
delivery service, flowkana.com
MICHAEL STEINMETZ:
What we really
like is being called
the Whole Foods of weed,
because we want me to be kind of
that higher echelon of quality.
We're about 100% transparency.
We connect patients directly
with value-based farmers
up in the Emerald
Triangle, a place known
in Northern California to
have pretty much the best
cannabis in the world.
And we believe in getting
really, really good medicine
to patients.
So you just go to flowkana.com
You open up the app.
You can browse our sample packs.
So we have the Active Pack,
you have the Inspired Pack,
Chill Pack, Zen Master Pack.
And then when you click
on one, it'll open up,
and it'll tell you a brief
description of the plant,
and it will also
show you who grew it.
And then you can very
easily add it to your cart.
LAURA LING: After an order
is placed and processed,
Mason jars of marijuana are
sent out by bike messenger
to be delivered door-to-door
as fast as pizza.
MICHAEL STEINMETZ:
When you work with us,
we're going to do the
best possible thing we
can to give you
the absolute best
medicine, the absolute
best customer service.
And we want everybody
to be totally
wowed from the minute they
use our app to the minute they
get our package
delivered to their home.
LAURA LING: From pot delivery
services, to marijuana yoga
sessions, to high-end
dinners featuring
different strains of
weed rather than wine,
a new cannabis
culture is emerging.
MICHAEL STEINMETZ:
And I think we're
going to start seeing
cannabis start being
more deeply integrated
into social environments
which you participate in.
When you go to have
dinner with your friends,
you have a little glass of wine.
Why wouldn't it be the case
that you could order a joint?
LAURA LING: And
pot entrepreneurs
like Michael are all
trying to get into a game
that they believe will explode
once recreational marijuana
becomes legal in California.
TROY DAYTON: In
this industry, this
is a market that already
exists, and it's just
bad laws that were in the way.
LAURA LING: Troy
Dayton is the CEO
of The ArcView Group, an
investment and research
firm devoted to the
cannabis industry.
TROY DAYTON: Once we were
on the cover of Fortune,
that's when a lot of the
calls started coming.
And over the last
two years or so,
we've seen about $41
million go to 54 companies.
LAURA LING: While pot use
is still illegal federally,
23 states and the
District of Columbia
have at least some form of
legal medical marijuana.
Four states and DC
have legalized it
for recreational use.
But legalization of recreational
pot use in California
could be a watershed.
GAVIN NEWSOM: California is
all of these other states that
have either moved
forward legalization
or are contemplating
legalization combined.
We're the largest producer
of marijuana in the nation.
But the impact will be felt
all across this country,
as is typical of a
state as large as ours
in scope and scale.
LAURA LING: How big do you
see this industry getting?
TROY DAYTON: Well, we predict
that if cannabis was regulated
like alcohol in all 50
states across the country,
that we'd be looking at
about a $36 billion market.
That doesn't include all
the ancillary businesses
that surround it, which
could probably eclipse that.
In 2014, it really
shifted out of just
being an interesting
cocktail conversation
and into being a unique American
dream kind of opportunity
for a lot of people.
LAURA LING: Up next, fine
dining with a side of weed.
SUBJECT: Now we're
doing four courses,
starting off with a
medicated amuse-bouche
before the four courses.
And in between each
course, we will be doing
intermezzo cannabis joints.
[MUSIC PLAYING]